>> Before we go any further,
just something you should know.
In particle filtering,
the measurements are typically
written as the z's,
z sub t and not as y of t.
It was just the way it was done.
It has to do with whether
you're connected to vision or
robotics in order it, so
that it aligns with various papers and
other formulations you'll see.
We're going to start s,
showing z's in the slides to come.
It also made it much easier to
borrow slides from other people,
because they were using the z's.
All right.
So the key to sort of particle
filtering is the following.
If we have a, a distribution and
here we have a nice little distribution,
which you see is, I don't know
what that distribution is, but
I know one thing, it's not Gaussian.
Now somebody who's really
smart out there might say,
well, it looks to me like
a mixture of Gaussians.
>> Well, it sort to looks to me
like a mixture of Gaussians.
>> Yeah, in this particular case,
maybe it is.
That's just for convenience of drawing.
And in fact, there is a relationship
between mixtures of Gaussians and
particle filters,
which we won't even talk about.
But basically,
it is you have a bunch of things with
together represent your density.
In particle filters or
sample based methods,
what you have is you have
a set of particles and
here the particles are drawn out
where you can see these particles.
It says, Xt.
That means these happen to be
our particles at time t and
there's n of them and, you know,
the bigger N is the better.
And you'll notice it says,
weighted here in parentheses,
because sometimes they're weighted or
sometimes they all have the same weight.
It, it, density is represented by
sort of where the particles are.
So you see we have a nice high
density here, so we have lots and
lots of particles there.
Okay?
Not so many particles here, not so
many here and lots of them there.
All right?
So that's where they are.
And if they were weighted,
it would be as if you,
you can think of that as having
two particles in the same spot.
If I double the weight, it'd be like
having two particles at the same spot.
And now you can say that the probability
density that x is some value is
essentially the probability, if you
were to draw out a particle that you
would get a particle whose value is
really, really close to that spot.
Okay?
And that's what it
means to use samples or
particles to represent
a particular density.
And if you're doing that,
then your overall goal is you want
sort of as n gets bigger, the idea
is that the probability of getting
a point from this distribution,
that's x is an element of xt
is a approximately what
the underlying probability was.
And for tracking, the idea is given
everything we've observed so far.
So what are our observations?
Remember, they're z's.
So given everything that we've observed
so far, what's our belief about where x
is and we want to end up with a set of
particles that gives us that density.